And now for something completely nuts.
Birds of Prey (And the Fantabulous Emancipation
of One Harley Quinn) has had its early preview
screenings, and audiences have taken to the
internet to voice their opinions.
The general consensus: the flick is a raunchy,
funny, very gory good time.
In case you've missed Birds of Prey's totally
bonkers trailer, the movie follows Margot
Robbie's Harley Quinn following her breakup
with Jared Leto's Joker from Suicide Squad,
who doesn't make an appearance in this film.
She's sucked into some nefarious plot involving
the notorious gangster Black Mask, played
by Ewan McGregor, and must eventually enlist
fellow badasses Black Canary and Huntress
to help protect young Cassandra Cain.
Robbie's Harley was one of Suicide Squad's
few bright spots, and audiences have been
anxiously awaiting her return to the role.
Birds of Prey is largely Harley's show and
those preview audiences haven't seen a goofy,
mayhem-driven comic book character so thoroughly
inhabited by an actor since the last Deadpool
movie.
Let's dig into what they had to say.
First things first: this isn't a comic book
film that you'll want to bring the kiddies
along for.
Birds of Prey is a hard-R, with copious amounts
of rough language and the kind of violence
usually reserved for Saw movies and the like.
One Reddit user posted a lengthy review of
the film in which he broke down just how inappropriate
Birds of Prey really is for the youngsters,
writing,
"This might be the goriest mainstream comic
book movie I've ever seen...There's a lot
of cursing, as well.
This is a movie that is really not met for
children.
It's pretty brutal.
I think teens will love this, though.
I think this will make John Wick numbers."
As far as just how enjoyable all of this mayhem
was, the Redditor was duly impressed, adding,
"It's way better than Suicide Squad.
The jokes are funnier...I thought Ewan McGregor
stole the show.
The actress who played Cassandra Cain was
also surprisingly good."
Over on Letterboxd, one user was enthralled
to see a group of kick-ass women, writing,
"The film doesn't make much sense.
But all my life I've seen films about guys
fighting without any reason.
And now, watching girls kicking some asses
for any reason, fills you with power.
[Is] this is what empowerment feels like?
Is this what boys feel when watching those
nonsense films?
GIVE ME MORE!"
Generally, the response to the film so far
is positive, with the vast majority of preview
audience members claiming that it's far superior
to Suicide Squad, which isn’t very hard
to do, and even belongs with the likes of
Wonder Woman and Shazam! among the best flicks
in the interconnected DC Extended Universe.
It's worth noting that these audience members
tended to exclude Joker from the discussions,
as it's understood to be completely separate
from the rest of DC's offerings.
Another Letterboxd user wrote,
"Margot Robbie is amazing as Harley Quinn,
and [Cassandra Cain] steals all the scenes...Ewan
as Black Mask is fantastic, the character
is sadistic and cruel, and he managed to convey
all the essence of the villain...It's a good
film, one of the best in DC."
"Hoo!
Who's having a good time?"
Another viewer concurred, while pointing out
that the flick is more than just a re-skin
of Marvel's popular R-rated franchise.
The user explained,
"Despite a confusing edit in the first act
and a slightly flat villain, [Birds of Prey]
delivers a fresh take on the superhero movies
field.
[It] should not be reduced to the 'female
Deadpool' as this one has more charm, a stronger
cast and is still interconnected to the [DC
Extended Universe]."
Finally, one particular audience member on
Letterboxd weighed in with an opinion that
we're not sure we can get behind, although
it is eloquent in its brevity.
They said simply,
"MCU IS DEAD."
Somehow, we doubt that Harley and pals will
be putting the final nail in the coffin of
that franchise but if there's any doubt that
the DCEU's course-correction after the stunning
failure of Justice League is in full swing,
Birds of Prey should put it to rest.
The flick opens wide on February 7th, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.